I love my buddy I did want to say one
thing about my buddy Richie who has a
disease and but it's it's an interesting
disease he as he has a disease of
alcoholism alcoholism and he came to me
you know and he told me and I like to
look I'm a kind of guy who likes to look
at the bright side of things you know so
I told him I said Richie is true that
you have a disease and everything but I
think you got the best one
the only disease where you get to drink
booze all the time I haven't looked at
every mythical journal but I believe
it's the only disease where you can
constantly drink booze clarified that is
the disease you know now they Richie
we're thinking you had to say like I
don't think Richie would go to my uncle
Burke oh hey I understand you got bowel
cancer ah man I know how you feel like a
drink a lot of booze those diseases
they're tough those diseases my uncle
Burt hey what's your symptoms uncle Burt
well my bowel I got blood pouring out of
it all the time I got bad blood pouring
out gushing out of my Bell almost
non-stop and I got searing Clym pains
the ripping tearing you know mind
screeching bowel pains and they're
combined with aching dull soul deadening
ballo pain those are basically my
symptoms how about you I get happy
and you know I tend to be able to talk
to people easier I find sometimes I will
meet a lady at a bar got the same
disease as I do and I'll [ __ ]
[Applause]
that's in the latter stages of the
disease uncle Bert yeah I fertilize that
all right